[Music]
a las vegas justice of the peace is
resigning
instead of facing a state ethics hearing
melanie tobiason's ethics trial was
scheduled to start in just a few weeks
it was sparked after an interview she
did with the eight news now i-team david
charn is live in studio here to tell us
about what exactly happened david
yeah brian as part of this deal the
ethics charges will be dropped in
exchange to bison agreed to resign next
week
the commission accused her of letting
her family influence her conduct while
on the bench
now in an interview with the i-team back
in 2018 tobiason accused law enforcement
agencies of ignoring
a local sex trafficking ring which she
says
tried to regrou recruit teenage girls
that is including the judge's own
daughter the judge told us she started
investigating the ring
herself hours i mean i would go i would
watch
i would get license plate numbers i
would get makes and models of cars i
would follow people i would get
information about where they would go
where they lived where they
you know i never used inappropriate
means to get information i did it all
myself
that interview from february of 2018
metro police started tracking to bison's
phone
once they thought she was interfering
with an investigation
they told the ethics commission she had
more than a thousand
communications over five months with an
unnamed organized crime figure
whom she had previously dismissed
charges against in her own courtroom
now this saga isn't fully over just yet
to bison is also suing the commission
in federal court saying they violated
her constitutional rights
and are trying to ruin her reputation